fifty-five-year-old laudelina sulueta is
returning home empty-handed after
spending hours in a queue to buy butter
life is a struggle she says especially
since her daughter migrated to spain
leaving her to care for her
grandchildren on her monthly minimum
wage worth twenty dollars at the black
market rate
hour
she shows us a refrigerator full mostly
of water
i have four children to feed i have no
choice but to go on the street to sell
this and that
she explains that she can buy 10 packs
of cigarettes for 200 pesos on her
ration card and sell each one for 150 on
the flourishing informal market
long lines for everything from food to
fuel revealed an economy in distress
people's tempers are short from cueing
most of the day in this case for two
bottles of oil
scarce items are sold with a ration card
but most things are no longer subsidized
i've been here since 5 00 a.m and i've
got number 117
see
it's now 10 a.m and there are at least
800 people in line hoping to buy chicken
cuba's cash-starved economy is
collapsing under the weight of harsh
economic sanctions imposed by washington
and a pandemic that's paralyzed tourism
cuba's economic engine
all this aggravated by three-digit
inflation sparked by a long overdue
monetary reform
we were obliged to devaluate our
currency by 2 300
one of the biggest devaluations ever
seen in the region
havana's state-run tourist hotels are
empty even as new ones are being built
the few russian tourists who came this
year left as soon as war broke out in
ukraine for fear of being unable to get
back home
thousands of ordinary cubans who
invested in bread and breakfasts before
the pandemic are now desperate here's
another sign where they rent rooms in
central havana i'm going to check to see
how they're doing
because there's a sign here that says
god bless my business and those who
visit but we'll see just how many
visitors they've had
[Music]
she hasn't had any since last year
with that income i could buy things for
my grandchild without it we're
the strategic planning chief says cuba
is trying to diversify its economy to
increase biotechnology industry exports
and food production
we have been taking measures to
strengthen and give more autonomy to our
state socialist enterprises which in our
view are the fundamental actors of our
economy
it's clear that maintaining centralized
control is still the priority despite
pleas for greater freedom for the
fledgling private sector
those who'd hoped that the way out of
this crisis would be to follow the
example of vietnam or china would just
have to keep waiting in line
the upcoming summit of the americas
which will be held in los angeles will
be the first opportunity for the cuban
and u.s presidents to sit down face to
face and discuss possible easing of u.s
sanctions against this country but that
will require political concessions on
the part of cuba